she's standing there like this was keira
knightley stays a long time she was like
she ran on kissed him yeah cuz she was
like I'm gonna Peck you all on the cheek
so you [ __ ] stop this [ __ ] it's
the holiday season folks are gathered
around with their families watching
their favorite holiday movies but what
is the best holiday movie some people
would say Love Actually other people not
so hot on it is Love Actually the new
holiday classic it's debatable
I'm here to tell you why this is
actually one of the worst movies I love
Love Actually Love Actually just gets me
angry club actually is the best I'm
gonna go sit the [ __ ] out of this movie
let's start with the actual film
structure barely about Christmas yeah
okay it's during Christmas time whatever
but it's not like we sit there and watch
them around a Christmas tree it's like
let's get this tabal Kade of big
celebrities throw them in mediocre
storylines and then just like get off on
watching people happen to cleverly
connect at points well a lot of the
characters were really creepy it wasn't
romantic at all like you kept that horny
Prime Minister horny you didn't want to
get involved with his secretary he found
her sexually attracted so he fired her I
wouldn't be you know down to clown with
that I would be like this is a little
weird
and I might be like where is HR let's
get into this Rick crime scene this
storyline is the absolute worst the only
reason he's using those signs is because
her husband is in the house imagine you
had you just got married to a guy and
then your best friend shows up at your
door with a sign saying don't tell Chloe
that I would never find out because he
didn't tell him also what a terrible
wedding videographer
I'm your paper one thing you had one job
Rick Grimes shoot the [ __ ] wedding
and everything concerning to this creepy
ass close-up of Keira Knightley I would
be like what the [ __ ] who are you you do
not lust after your best friend's girl
especially when they're getting married
that's just like block that [ __ ] off
buddy then there's this little kid that
decides he's in love with someone after
like pretty much never speaking for
which is fine but he decides to go to
the airport you wouldnt be able to run
through any security for that I will say
that this is post 2001 this is post 9/11
so that kid probably would have been
tased [ __ ] out Rob Lowe
first of all in Love Actually you've one
of the best cast ever you never get
bored because there's always something
different to watch you just feel so many
things and watching this movie mostly
discussed and think it's self-aware you
know I know some people think that scene
with the guy from The Walking Dead is
creepy yes it is slightly creepy but it
is also like very romantic and he's
still mean good to his friends because
he's not trying to pursue his friend's
wife he's just trying to let her know
that he doesn't hate her I was a film
major okay I'm appreciating it for what
it is it's a frickin holiday movie like
calm down everybody it's just a bit of
fun
Martin Freeman is in it that's he's one
of the best people ever and he's so
adorable isn't he like a sex stand-in in
this movie yeah so the lot of the film
is actually very British based which
might be why some Americans don't really
understand it you gotta watch it with
mom you gotta watch it with your mom you
gotta watch it with your sister I don't
have a sister I just pretend I have one
I never watch it any other time of the
year because it's a Christmassy movie
and it gets me in the spirit we will cry
and laugh and get angry together about
it I also got to hear all I want for
Christmas is you buy Mariah Carey in
like an amazing falsetto voice and it
totally inspired me to sing that as an
11 year old at my Christmas party I
don't go into watching Christmas movies
expecting the next Citizen Kane but this
gave it a well-rounded fun experience
that I can come back to year after year
and that doesn't get old
basically all the men in this movie are
trash oh you need a closing argument oh
my god so rude love can be crazy the
love as it actually is weird and messy
just let people enjoy themselves it's a
fun movie love actually makes no sense
there are so many more stories crammed
into one it's a completely rambling
story just like you're bored in the end
between the Battle of good and evil love
actually wins
you were told seven words or less he
can't count
I just didn't count I chose not to like
the film